and you might say well what's your
evidence that those differences in
personality aren't culturally
constructed in the evidence for that
quite clear you go online you can look
up the Scandinavian studies go online
and look up gender differences in
personality cross culturally you'll find
the relevant studies they've been done
with tens of thousands people and what
they showed we're clearly is that in
those societies where the mostly be done
to move smooth the social world into a
position of radical equality and so that
would probably be the Scandinavian
countries because they've got more than
that more about in any other country the
personality differences between men and
women maximise they don't minimize they
maximize and I'll say that again
in the countries where the most has been
done to equalize the playing field
between men and women men women get more
difference rather than more the same so
for all your social constructionist so
their audiences is probably not that
many of you because you wouldn't come
and hear me talk socially you're
actually drawn yeah
well the thing is
so these so one of the things you might
have is that it's all the same to me
subsets like when I was looking into
this to begin with in this river started
probably 25 years ago looking at
differences in personality between men
and women you know it's all whether they
were fundamentally biological biological
or fundamental sociological or what
makes produced the differences you know
of you and the most logical hypothesis
really hypothesis as utilize the society
that the men and women would become more
the same that is not what happened and
so we've actually what the social
constructionist hypothesis with regards
to gender differences in incest and
personality we'll put that to the test
in a very intense way and the social
constructs this people won't fail so
it's very strange because no one would
really believe that right if you make
this make society more the same you men
and women get going on so what's up with
that well the answer seems to be is that
there's fundamentally two sources of
variability in personality right there's
perhaps more but you can categorize them
as broccoli genetics and gruffly so see
barking well you take out all the
sociological differences between the
landscape in which men women rated all
you have left are the biological and
genetic differences so they maximize the
left examine without the data analysis
it really sounds and this is what
demands for equity also 1215 reasons
what the master equity order offices
between men and women should not be over
well partly because it's wrong to
overlook the journey with differences
between men upon it's not good for them
and it's not good for the women so what
are the things you see in Scandinavia
for example it is an overwhelming
preponderance of female nurses and
there's an overwhelming preponderance of
male engineers and actually the data on
on personality differences there's the
standard traits which all continues go
through how to do that
quickly is almost difference in trade
conscientiousness between men and women
if you break it down into the opspecs
women are bit more orderly than men but
there's no difference in adult business
and then with regards to openness which
is the intelligence creativity dimension
overall there's no difference between
men and women but if you bring it up
into the aspects then the differences
are actually quite pronounced so what
you have is that openness to experience
is the technical truth and it's roughly
breaks down into something that's sort
of like Priya's creativity and instead
of interests versus interest in ideas
and what you see is that women are third
the standard deviation higher demand in
terms of creativity and aesthetic
aesthetic for polygamy let's say and men
are month or the standard deviation
higher than women in terms of interest
in ideas and it's not a trivial
difference and it makes a difference so
but the biggest difference between men
and women else turns out this is almost
one standard deviation which is a
walloping difference you never see that
in social science and math the
difference is on difference between
difference in interest and the masculine
interest roughly speaking is in things
and then female interest roughly
speaking is in people and that's what
underlies the difference is saying in
interest preference between things like
nursing and psychology and social work
in that and that sort of thing and
engineering and because engineering is
across the most male oriented of all the
disciplines
the evidence that that's sociological
spirit you're asleep